la route de la mort la route qui mène de
Bagdad à Nadjaf partout des carcasses de
véhicules exposés témoignage des
embuscades tendu par les groupes armés
clandestins c'est sur cette route qui a
disparu un grand nombre des étrangers
pris en otage
[Musique]
la plupart sont repérés ici à Mahmoud ya
au niveau de ce marché où les voitures
sont obligé de ralentir
[Musique]
non non non pas là
dégage dégage
c'est sur cette route que notre confrère
Christian Chesnot et Georges Malbrunot
ont disparu le 20 août dernier le
tronçon le plus dangereux c'est ici
entre le marché de Mahmoud ya est la
ville de laticia le fief des groupes les
plus radicaux de la Résistance irakienne
c'est la première fois depuis
l'enlèvement des deux journalistes
français avec une caméra entre dans la
ville
Christian et Georges sont sans doute des
tenues quelque part dans la région
ici le message est clair
au nom de Dieu le clément et
miséricordieux je vous parle au nom des
habitants de Laetitia nous ne voulons
plus voir d'Américains ici à la City à
nous ne voulons plus voir ni de
caméraman de photographies de
journalistes
nous ne voulons faire de la part des
Américains plus d'un gérant
pour tourner ces images nous avons dû
faire appel à un cameraman Iraqiya
pourtant sur la route du retour il est
lui-même la cible des groupes armés
on nous a tiré dessus
ils ont touché la voiture et maintenant
je ne sais pas ce qui va nous arriver
[Musique]
de retour à Bagdad Zac notre cameraman
nous raconte ce qu'il n'a pas pu filmer
les ballons toucher le pneu ici et là
c'est pour ça qu'on a dû s'arrêter les
tirs venait de derrière moi
alors j'ai caché la caméra devant moi et
j'ai filmé le pneu
[Musique]
j'ai fait comme ça
maintenant ensuite j'ai éteint la caméra
et je l'ai caché ici sur le pneu
et je me suis tourné vers eux en disant
ok ok
si je veux je peux te mettre une balle
dans la tête
l'hôtel Palestine une véritable
forteresse qui abrite depuis la fin de
la guerre la majorité des journalistes
étrangers il y a 2 mois encore vivent et
ici le présentateur vedette de la
télévision polonaise
il est mort avec son cameraman assassiné
dans cette voiture sur la route de Nadja
ce jour-là c'est-à-dire qu'il conduisait
l'équipe de journaliste
regarder 1 2 3 4 5 6 impact de balle sur
le repose-tête j'ai regardé il y en a
d'autres ici
vous pensez retravailler ici avec des
journalistes en Irak non c'est fini moi
je travaille plus
pourquoi j'ai trop peur vous savez même
dans mon quartier les gens pensent
maintenant je suis un espion la seule de
des étrangers
ne nous respecte plus
mais les deux autres en face de chez moi
et comment vous voyez votre avenir il
n'y a plus de futur pour moi ici dans ce
pays mon espoir c'est parti
c'est plaisant c'était mon rêve c'est
moi qui l'ai construit et maintenant je
dois tout abandonner
la famille âge on dit elle aussi ça
prête à quitter l'Irak c'est moi Mad le
père qui a accompagné avec Christian
Chesnot et Georges Malbrunot à Nadia
cela fait 22 jours qu'il est retenu avec
les deux Français et man son fils
s'occupe de la famille
comme vous pouvez le voir nous sommes en
train de déménager
pour pas vous partez
parce que c'est trop dangereux tout le
monde nous connaît tout le monde connaît
notre histoire et vous savez ici en Irak
si les gens entendu dire que vous
travaillez pour des étrangers ils sont
tout de suite que vous travaillez pour
des Américains
mais c'est pas vrai
et vous madame vous pensez que votre
mari courait des risques parce qu'il
travaille avec des Français n'ont jamais
jamais
lorsque nous marchons dans la rue avec
Christian et Georges nous n'avions rien
à craindre
les enfants à l'école avec mon mari
il était très proche il ne se quittait
jamais
les algues sont des Syriens exilés en
Irak depuis plus de 20 ans depuis
l'enlèvement ils sont régulièrement
menacer
j'espère que l'on pourra prendre le plus
de choses possible parce que cette
maison c'est ma maison depuis 19 ans et
c'est pas facile de tout quitter
je voudrais leur dire à tous les trois
soyez saints et sauf et que Dieu vous
garde
nos cœur sont avec vous
et tout ce qu'on espère c'est que vous
rentriez à la maison
je ne sais pas quoi vous dire d'autre
je ne peux plus parler
s'il te plaît arrête de pleurer sinon je
vais pleurer ça
je t'en prie arrête
c'est dans cet hôtel que vivait les deux
journalistes français quand il était à
Bagdad c'est ici qu'ils sont partis le
20 août dernier pour Nadia il y a 2
jours la nouvelle de l'enlèvement en
plein Bagdad de deux ressortissante
italienne a choqué tout le monde ça avec
Abdoulaye me et le fils du patron de
l'hôtel
aujourd'hui c'est les Italiens ensuite
ce sera des Américains après des Anglais
ils peuvent entrer prendre n'importe qui
même ici dans cet hôtel
mais
maintenant il va falloir que nous soyons
tous armés
et comme ça on sera prêt
il y a 2 semaines si on vous avait dit
que deux Français seraient t'enlever
chez vous vous l'auriez cru
non
j'aurais pas cru
pourtant Sadek et son père ont été un
moment soupçonné d'avoir aidé à
l'enlèvement d'autres membres de la
tribu Abdoulaye mis à laquelle ils
appartiennent sont très proches de la
Résistance et deux autres journalistes
de leur hôtel ont déjà été enlevé
regarder c'était leur chambre la chambre
on a dit que c'était vous qui avait
dénoncé les Français
ici
par exemple
c'est pas possible
Philippe Robert lui et journaliste et
américain
on pensait que les enveloppes elle
aurait pu prévenir les kidnappeurs
non ce n'est pas comme ça que les choses
se passent ici
on
est
le groupe qui a enlevé les deux
journalistes français
de l'islam
c'est ici dans cette mosquée l'une des
plus grande de Bagdad que se trouve le
chèque m'a dit aller sur ma taille la
plus haute autorité pour les salafistes
Iraqi
officiellement il n'a aucun contact
direct avec l'Armée islamique d'Irak qui
a revendiqué d'enlèvement
pourtant même s'il y a 4 jours il a
exigé la libération des deux
journalistes français il soutient le
combat de l'Armée islamique même quand
celle-ci exécute c'est otage le
journaliste italien Enzo baldoni et est
innocent est-ce qu'il a payé pour le
crime du gouvernement italien oui bien
sûr et les journalistes polonais aussi
ont payé pour les fautes de leur
gouvernement oui bien sûr
on peut dire que c'est innocent ont été
rendu coupable par les crimes de leur
pays se sont des soldats italien qui ont
tué de nombreux diras qui a un spa et
les américains ils n'ont pas fait la
même chose ils n'ont pas tué des
milliers de irakien pourquoi personne ne
parle de saisir à qui a une sanction te
tuer
pour les Français on a déjà dit qu'on
les considérais pas comme des ennemis
car ils n'ont pas envahi notre pays
dans les coulisses de la négociation on
espère beaucoup de cet appel à la
clémence des autorités salafistes sur le
marché au voleur de Bagdad on ne se
soucie pas beaucoup plus du sort des
otages au contraire même dans les
arrière-boutique on s'arrache des DVD
des exécutions ou des attaques de convoi
ça c'est bien des opérations contre les
Américains oui c'est ça
et ça c'est quoi tous les DVD en face de
vous sont des opérations de la
Résistance Yerres le DVD de le plus
copier dans cette boutique montrer la
décapitation d'un otage égyptien son
corps a été retrouvé dimanche dernier
dans le nord de Bagdad des images trop
pas soutenable pour vous les montrer
regarder tous le chat
ce qui trahissent la nation
il n'y aurait plus que nous sommes des
hommes de principe
Aymane le fils du traducteur de Georges
Malbrunot et Christian Chesnot viens à
l'ambassade de France prendre des
nouvelles de son père des tenues avec
les deux Français c'est un agent de
sécurité qui le prend en charge vous
voyez pour l'instant nous n'avons pas
nouvelles informations
c'est pour ça que l'ambassadeur a pris
la décision d'être très prudent
pas donner de faux espoirs
ça ne servira à rien
donc en fait il n'y a pas de nouvelles
non pas encore
depuis hier l'Armée islamique en Irak
amusé a pris la tête des maman elle
accuse de collaborer avec les Amériques
faites attention mon pistolet armée
pourquoi vous portez un pistolet
parce que je pense que je suis en danger
surtout depuis les appels anonymes
que disent les appels c'est très étrange
parce que ce ne sont pas vraiment des
menaces mais ça on a tout l'air quand il
s'appelle il demande où est ton père tu
sais où il est comment va-t-il je ne
sais pas
mais tu sais qui nous sommes on te
rappelle plus tard il raccroche et aucun
numéro n'apparaît sur le portable nous
n'aurons pas la permission d'assister à
la réunion entre Ayman et les membres de
l'ambassade
le rendez-vous durera une demi-heure
et maman comment ça va
vous savez je suis vraiment très inquiet
pour la vie de mon père parce que même
si Dieu veut
je ne sais pas si il sera en sécurité
ici
c'est
pour vous aider